lovely i'm standing here live now he'll
be there in 10 seconds
thank you
right good evening and welcome to
tonight's uh
virtual planning committee for stratford
district council um
my name's danny kendall and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting in accordance
with the rules and procedures
and set out in our usual agendas um so
we're clear i'm not the usual chairman
i'm having to sit in for council richard
tonight who is unwell and uh
we can send him our best wishes and hope
hope has a speedy recovery
um right housekeeping before we get
started uh the council's got a guide
uh to etiquette virtual meetings which
you'll all be aware of
uh the most important details of course
though uh to ensure your device is fully
charged uh and that you mute your
microphone when you're not
speaking um please turn it off when you
finish speaking as well
remember please switch mobile phones to
silent and i'll just double check mine
is as well
as we are all sorted um
if members uh encounter any con
connection issues during the course of
the meeting do your best to try and
rejoin
but if you can't uh we'll continue um
and
we'll assume you have left the meeting
at that point so long as the meeting
uh continues to be quarantined um
please be aware meeting courses being uh
live recorded and live webcast
uh images may be used for training
purposes in the future
uh for the members of the public just to
establish this it was
uh confirmed in front of our legal
representative before the meeting
started that all members of the
committee
have um read all documentation the
update sheets and can see
and hear the proceedings right now as we
go through them
okay uh i think if i'll do a few quick
introductions
um we have with us tonight olivia quinn
who's our community services
representative
we have ross chambers our legal
representative
uh alice cosnet who will be our planning
manager
uh we also have offices amy flute
robert parker gulliford charlotte dix
and paul thompson
alice if i can come back to you did you
have a statement you'd like to make at
this point
yes thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members
in their decision taking thank you
that's
wonderful thank you for that alice okay
um we move then i think
the first item on our journey tonight
just apologies for absence
thanks chair we've got apologies from
councillors richards
fleming adam eden and parry
marvelous thank you for that uh do we
have any
disclo hang on i'm
just checking i'm not muted there we are
sorry uh do you have any uh
any disclosure of interest from any
members of the committee if you'd like
to indicate in the chat i'll just pause
for a second
the chat seems quiet and there's lots of
shaking ahead so we'll move on
um can i item three is to confirm the
minutes of the previous meeting held on
the 20th
of january are you all content that i
sign those if you just
give me a thumbs up everybody if you're
happy with that okay those could be
signed and due course thank you
everybody
right in that case let's move on to the
main part of tonight's agenda
okay item four found on page 11 of your
agendas
um is application reference
19-0-3-4-8-2-f-u-l it's the cleveland
tennis court station road cleveland and
it's the direction of nine floodlights
presenting officer on this is amy flute
amy
if you're ready to go over to you thank
you chairman let me just
share my screen with you
can i just double check that everybody
can see that
perfect thank you great thank you
the application site denoted by the
black dot
is an existing tennis club within the
village of clavidon
the site is washed over by the green
belt
the application site edged red is
situated within the conservation area
and is nearby to a number of listed
buildings which are
coloured red the site flanks
church road to the east and park
drive to the south
planning permission is sought for the
erection of nine 6.12 metre high
floodlight columns
with 10 lights in total to serve the two
existing tennis courts
the columns will have one light with the
exception of column five
which will have two lights
the lighting columns will be constructed
from galvanized steel
and the phillips light will be
constructed from die cast aluminium
the elements could be painted either
dark green
or black this image
is taken looking towards the application
site in a southerly direction
the existing two courts can be seen
within the exist
can be seen with the existing hedgerow
that is outside of the application site
running along the eastern and southern
boundaries the reeves of neighbouring
properties can be seen above the hedge
line
this image shows the eastern boundary
and part of the existing tennis court
the footpath that serves church road can
be seen where the land level falls away
this image is taken outside of the
application site on church road looking
in a north easterly direction towards
the a4189
the image shows the existing hedgerow
that is outside of the application
site the footway that serves the tennis
court
and wider community facilities of church
lane can now be seen
the tennis court is on higher ground
level by comparison to church lane
this image is taken outside of the
application site looking in a
southwesterly direction
the neighboring property wheel rights
can be seen adjacent to the park drive
junction
again outside of the application site
looking east down
park drive towards church road the
tennis courts are the other side of the
hedge which can be seen
the proposal represents inappropriate
development within the green belt
in addition it is considered that the
proposal will harm the landscape and
setting of heritage assets
it is not considered that there are
sufficient very special circumstances
and public benefits to outweigh the
identified harm chairman the
recommendation
is to refuse the application as detailed
within the committee report
please also note that there are some
updates on the update sheet thank you
that's wonderful thank you for that amy
um right we go to our first speaker
olivia can you confirm is it start and
zero tom mute or star in six i'm sorry
i've forgotten
it's star six but it looks like they're
all unmuted
so we should be okay so in that case we
go to our first speaker tonight council
simon lawton
parish council councilman
thank you chair yes i am that's
wonderful uh
council could you would you mind muting
the um presentations going on the
background for me please
okay thank you for that council autumn
well you have three minutes uh if you
make sure you remain on the line at the
end for any questions please
um we'll give you a warning at the last
10 seconds if that's okay
that's no problem thanks over to you
then sir thank you uh good evening
committee um
members will have read the parish
council's reason for sporting this
application we're a little surprised in
respect of the planning officer's
decision to recommend refusal our
reasons for support are clearly outlined
on page 13 of your report
below these are a number of objections
and of several supports from
parishioners
of the objections it seems that a very
few are actually based on solid planning
grounds
councillors need to consider planning
issues raised by the office are not
nimbyism there are three
one impacts on listed buildings in a
conservation area now whilst the site
doesn't join some listed buildings and
was until 25 years ago a recreation
field
the whole site has since been developed
to provide adopted surgery pharmacy
a kindergarten a tennis club and a
community shop
these are all welcomed in the
conservation area while the improvements
of the tennis club facility should fall
foul of conservation green belt issues
seems spurious
and the short term occasional use of the
facility is unlikely to cause
substantial harm as
stated in the officer's report secondly
there is a perception that cleveland is
a dark village
well this is nonsense the village has
flood lighting at the red line
pub around the corner from the site
lighting on the listed forge of joining
the site
and in other village conservation areas
the crown home has flood lighting 20
yards from the oldest 15th century
farmhouse in the village
lots of other areas have lighting so
although we do not have street lights
this is not in any way a special
situation or valid reason to refuse
occasional sports lighting
other neighboring tennis clubs have
lighting why not cloud them
and thirdly the development would not
benefit the wider
community well yes it would young
members of our village do not have the
ability
to have local tennis coaching during the
winter cleveland has several sporting
recreational offers that nearly died
over the past few years
a concerted community effort to
encourage mini youth
training has rescued claremont football
club our rugby club has now
many ex-minis playing first and seconds
and the village has recently invested
140 000 pounds to provide facilities
for boys and girls cricket which will
sustain the future years of former
founding village club
it's likely important youth sport is
supported and to this end we have had
many grants from sport england
let me conclude councillors the three
planning reasons about are far from
justified in the office's conclusion
and our neighborhood plan has always
also been somewhat misconstrued
it does confirm that the plan
which clearly supports the improvement
of sporting facilities and villages
any suggestion of harm far outweighs the
benefits so please vote to approve this
application from benefit
village that said councillors um i would
appreciate the opportunity to answer
any comments that you may have
that's wonderful thank you council
lawton uh we do have our first question
from uh councillor jennings
council jennings thank you chairman
uh thank you councillor just a quick
quick couple of questions one was a bit
of a long shot so you probably won't
know this but i'll ask it anyway
um first of all i'm sure you will know
this one uh just to confirm
are there any street lights in cleveland
i don't know there are
okay the answer to that is no there are
we we don't have street lights
and uh as as quite a number of villages
the same size as clarendon don't have
streetlights
okay and you mentioned about the pubs
having floodlights
um do you by any chance know how tall
they
are well the the floodlights
on the red lion which is literally 50 or
well probably about 60 or 70 yards from
the site
um they are mounted in the car park and
on the buildings so i would
i would say they are probably around
six to seven meters high on the uh
the crown inn which is uh again right in
the middle of the conservation area
those again are mounted on the building
and i'd say they're
probably in excess of seven eight meters
high
they they actually flood the entire car
park it's a car park there
50 cars 60 cars same as the red line
it's a big car park it's completely
flood lit
and so the idea that cleveland is
somehow
a dark village you know dating back to
the 18th century is
is dawn's thank you council
lawton thank you okay we move to
councillor crumb
good evening council how are you today
simon
i'm very good thanks andy and yourself
yeah that's it thank you
uh just a cookie um obviously no uh i've
done well played qriket there and
might have actually gone in the red line
for for a glass of lemonade but uh
so i do know it quite well a couple of
things um
in the report um you mentioned that
junior coaching
that they would have to go elsewhere if
this wasn't uh
available where would they likely to go
and how far would that be please
well the the nearest clubs are uh are
snitterfield which is probably about um
i would say 10-15 miles away there is
henley which is probably the nearest
which is
about seven or eight miles away um
and allen hall which is probably a
little bit further about 10 miles away
but the point is councilman trump that
we don't want our villagers to go and
join other clubs because
they join clavidon they make friends
with
with kids at cleveland tennis clubs and
they stay for the rest of their career
yeah precisely and and it's like to say
i've always a big believer in positivity
around sport
thank you for that yeah so yeah again
it's just about
the sustainability that traveling
you know you're saying that they could
tell what up to 10 to 15 miles if this
facility wasn't there
uh and can i just ask another one cancer
kendall please
is associated um what other
i know you said that the other clubs are
doing pretty well
um the rugby and the cricket but what
other night time activities are there
that um these people could have if this
wasn't there you know i'm just again
from a youth youth opportunity
uh reducing anti-social behavior you're
giving them something to do
and youth facilities really if you see
one coming from china
yeah i sort of get get your point i mean
the only
evening facility that is used by kids at
the moment is the
is the clown of the rugby club which has
polled flood lighting
up to eight meters um they train with
the senior players
on a tuesday and occasionally on a
thursday evening during the winter
without that you wouldn't be able to
have a mini section because there will
be no time for them to train
thank you very much have a good evening
thank you
thank you our our last question is from
councillor mills please
yeah thanks richard hi simon good
evening good to have you
good evening um actually most of the
question answered uh was going to ask
about but
just a quickie the uh the tennis club
itself
is it busy during the day and then come
five o'clock
nothing i mean is it very very busy
during the day
it is it's it's a well-used club um
obviously during the day it tends to be
well certainly not um
under current circumstances it tends to
be more seniors obviously people who are
not at work
and it tends to be busier at the weekend
with with younger members who obviously
can't
play during the week uh certainly not
not during working hours
and uh we we think that you know the
occasional flood lighting here
is uh is perfectly acceptable to allow
not only kids to to play at night but
obviously some members of the public who
wouldn't be able to as they've got work
commitments
okay thanks simon thank you
thank you for that uh final question
from me please simon if that's okay
if we were minded to grant the
application
um would you be content with time limits
so
something like uh you know it has to be
switched off by nine o'clock or
something like that would that be
something you would find
acceptable oh i think the parish council
would have no objection to that in fact
we have proposed at 9
30 and i understand that the club have
got
some technical ability whereby you can't
actually physically have
lights on after after a certain time
they can actually it's almost
it's almost like you know putting a
penny in the slot machine
and if it goes off it goes off so there
is a way of limiting it
and then we would be happy to see that
installed as well
that's fine thank you very much for that
okay i don't think we have any further
questions for you so councillor lawton
thank you very much for your time
tonight much appreciated
thank you very much chair have a good
evening you too bye-bye
okay we go now to our next speaker uh
speakers i think
we've got objectors here tom dougherty
on behalf of the trustees of dorothy
mitchell hall
trust and bill farmer who's a local
resident
um mr doughty are you there please
i am chair thank you thank you um shall
we go to you first if that's okay
you're splitting the time between you so
you have four minutes um would you like
us to give you a
warning at the last 10 seconds last 30
seconds yes please chair thank you
okay in that case over to you thank you
chair i and committee members i
represent the dorothy mitchell hall
trust which is the charity which owns
the land encompassing the application
site
and the wider grounds and buildings
which include a doctor's surgery nursery
community shop and other village on-site
functions
and being responsible for the upkeep and
maintenance of the london building the
trust raises funds through rental income
from tenants
and hall lettings rental incomes are
below market value because of the
original trust endowment
and this means that the functions at the
hall are of critical importance to the
viability of the site
the most frequent and important
functions are weddings
these usually take place over the
weekend and into the evenings when the
tennis club is not operating
the hall is very popular with many
couples citing its appearance and
setting as a reason for their choice
the trust is therefore concerned that by
allowing the proposed flood lighting the
future of these bookings may be
adversely affected
the impact of the visual appearance of
the site particularly when planning
wedding photos
is important therefore the proposed nine
large industrial looking flood lights
will detract from the rest of the
setting
the flood lighting will allow the use of
the tennis courts to continue
later into the day and evening which
will affect wedding guests using the
site in general with disturbance light
auto and also entering the hall during
functions
any significant reduction in income from
these events may force the trustees to
seek an increase in rent from tenants
to make good the shortfall and that in
turn could affect the viability of a
number of other facilities on the site
in addition to the business risk the
trust objects to the provision of the
lights
on the grounds of impact on an important
community facility
which is specifically contrary to policy
csl2 of the claverden neighborhood plan
which states that proposals which
enhance existing sport and recreational
facilities
will be supported where they are
compatible with neighbouring uses
this proposal is not felt to be
compatible with neighbouring uses and as
such has felt to be contrary to policy
in addition to uh to this
in the cleveland neighborhood plan there
are a number of other policies which the
trust consider
the proposal is contrary to and i'll
briefly highlight these now
policy csl1 seeks to protect the
existing community facilities
and the accompanying explanatory text
within the neighborhood plan
explains that the application site and
surrounding area
suffer from parking issues given the use
of the haw for functions such as
weddings at weekends
the increase in activity at the tennis
courts that would occur
as a result of the proposed lights would
exacerbate this issue
policy be one principles of good design
sets out how development within the
village should be designed
and the criteria to be considered this
includes how the village design
statement has been considered
the design statement specifically
discourages street lighting and security
lighting
and whilst it acknowledged that this
lighting is for a different purpose the
principle we feel should be applied
the statement also seeks to maintain
local character
the prevailing character of clavidon is
one of dark skies which would be
adversely affected by these lights in
such a prominent position
policy ne 5 conserving the natural
environment states that development
proposals
must along with a number of measures to
benefit biodiversity
reduce light pollution in order to be
supported
it must therefore follow that proposal
that significantly
increases 30 seconds
policy be2 heritage assets seeks to
prevent harm to the conservation area
enlisted buildings
and as you are aware from your office's
report this proposal is within the
conservation area
and the siter joins listed buildings the
impact of
nine flood lighting columns of over six
meters in height
far in excess of the height of any other
flood lighting in the village
can also be considered as a negative and
therefore the proposal is
contrary to policy and the trust
therefore objects to the application the
hopes that the members of the planning
committee
will refuse the application in line with
their officers recommendation
thank you very much mr chair thank you
mr dougherty can i pause to see if there
are any questions from the committee at
this point please
councilor mills please if you'd like to
ask your question
yes thanks mr chairman good evening um
i'm not sure if i quite understood are
you saying that the
uh the floodlights would interfere with
the
photography of um if there was a wedding
uh reception taking place
uh or did i misunderstand i i think it's
slight misunderstanding we feel that the
visual
appearance of the flood lighting being
an industrial lighting column basically
uh will detract from from the uh
the visual you know appearance and
setting that somebody who's having their
wedding photos taken on the grass area
outside the hall which they do at the
moment uh
they may not they may not feel that
that's an appropriate uh location to
have to have their wedding photos taken
in front of
enjoying lighting columns yes i did miss
understand
so thank you thank you thank you uh next
question from councillor crump please
yeah um firstly how many
how many weddings do you roughly have
during the year and and
secondly uh so we it concerns
on the impact on on your your income
and secondly i did think you said
something about
the lights um not only the impact of the
columns but the lights being on
and well i might have misunderstood that
but those lights are not
going to be on at the weekend according
to the officers report on page 13.
um so did i miss here that [ __ ] as well
so yeah one
how many how many um weddings and two
uh am i correct about the
lights you said about the lights being
on it and interfering with the
weddings as well okay um
obviously in a normal non-curvature we
probably have around
12 weddings or so a year we're
restricted
anyway in the number of weddings we can
have because if we have to be aware of
the noise and nuisance
effects that such gatherings may happen
surrounding residents
so we have to be aware of that um
the best way i can probably describe the
the income that we get from the hall is
that it probably makes up about fifty
percent of our total site income
so we probably get about 50 of our our
revenue
from tenants which would be the nursery
and doctor's surgery etc
and then the other 50 would be from
functions primarily weddings but also
from birthday parties and and such like
that
okay anything else you needed it was i
was like
did i was here when you said you thought
not only the the size of the columns
that
yeah but also the the light from them
would
uh impact potentially on on the weddings
i wasn't sure what i missed here about
because if that was the case
that i'm not having the lights on at the
weekend so that's that was my other
points then
right well uh the only thing i would say
on that is
is i would imagine that weekends would
be a prime
prime evening time would be when they
probably want to use the course
those are the times where most people
are available
um so we're assuming that if that
facility is there to be used that at
some time in the future
the tennis club are going to use that
facility and from discussions with other
uh sports clubs other tennis clubs for
example warwick tennis club we've spoken
to the residents around
there and those those facilities are
used uh
you know can be used seven days a week
yeah obviously we have to
what's in front of us um and i think
from
what the chairman said earlier to uh the
paris council
if we were minded to put a condition on
if it was agreed that we would
there would be no floodlights in the
weekend evening so
um so just clarifying those points so
that's all from me thank you okay thank
you thank you and our final question i
think
is from cancer jennings thank you
chairman
thank you very much um the you mentioned
that the lights are
proposed or a lot higher than any of the
other lights
um in the village and i know again when
i asked
councillor lorton obviously he
guesstimated at them
i wonder if you could guestimate on some
of the the lights
[Music]
the best way to consider this if you
consider the flood lighting on the crown
it's a two-story building
um the average height of a story in an
in an old building is probably two two
and a half meters at most
so those flood lights which are mounted
under the eaves that face onto the main
road
are probably at a height of about four
meters four to four and a half meters
okay excellent thank you very much
fantastic thank you ross
uh ross chambers uh you've indicated
you'd like to come in at this point
do you want to make a comment now yeah
thanks chair it was just in relation to
councillor crump's points um
i didn't recall the parish council
saying
they wouldn't have lighting at weekends
i think what they said is they wouldn't
have lighting beyond
9 30 in the evening i think you're quite
correct uh ross i think
what we're doing is very important
thanks to the report ross
yeah it's it's noted in the in the
supporting section from the parish
council it's one of their suggestions
but thank you for having us okay um in
that case uh
mr dougherty thank you very much for
your time this evening it was much
appreciated
uh thank you feel free to hang up and
continue watching on the on the website
now if you like
we we move now to um uh like resident mr
bill
farmer mrs farmer
good evening mr chairman council yes i'm
here
thank you for waiting well sir you have
two minutes we'll give you a warning at
the last 30 seconds if that's okay
and then you could stay on for any
questions over to you
thank you further objections include
reflected light from court surfaces is a
major source of light pollution
and then so much as it's excluded from
the applicant's data
not included in the figure it causes a
serious shortfall in our understanding
a massive 400 lux of light will strike
the court's surface
and a significant amount will reflect
towards and cause light wash over nearby
properties
and also cause sky glow the actual
effect should have been quantified by
calculation
or site trials and tests to enable
proper understanding
two the dm bass many of us have seen
bats in and around the vm site
to behave recklessly with regard to
their roots and hibernation sites is an
offence in law
you know there has been no back further
no inspection by a competent person of
all the sites buildings and the
surroundings
to establish the presence of the bats or
otherwise and their risk from the light
it seems that to proceed without said uh
inspection or survey
could be construed as reckless
three tennis court light is sorry tennis
court use is minimal
pre-lockdown late october half term
early november
i noted when walking through the site
uh in the day as follows out of 29
occasions
i 58 court availability stock
court was in use just five times and
seven slots used
so that's twelve percent usage
for adults number four the weight of the
providence resident's opinion against
the light is pretty massive
letters and comments over the three
iterations of the applications
are 4 42 against
204 that's 83 percent
against or if you'd actually take the
clavidne residence
442 against 91
now that's 68 percent
has elapsed but uh i'll ask members if
there are any further questions for you
that's okay
uh members if you'd like to indicate if
there are any questions in the uh chat
that'll be handy please
it remains quiet i think that means
there are no further questions
i think this fun we have got the gist of
of where you were going with with your
objection i think that we're content
with that thank you very much for your
time tonight of hanging around it's much
appreciated
so thank you thank you all right right
uh we move then to our final speaker on
this application this is uh
charles robinson the agent for the
applicant mr robinson are you there
yes i am can you hear me yes wonderful
thank you
right uh so you have three minutes as as
before if you um
would remain on the line at the end for
any questions and we'll give you a
warning at 30 seconds if that's okay
thank you chad over to you thank you uh
thank you for this opportunity i am the
planning consultant
advising the club on this matter and i'm
also a tennis player
but in terms of the principle of
development it is acknowledged
that the proposal is supported by
policies within the core strategy and
the neighbourhood plan
the harm identified in the offices
report relates to
the openness of the green belt as well
as heritage assets
and any harm which is identified is
limited and less than substantial
and in that matter i'm in full accord
with the officer's report
all development has to have some impact
and it's the role of the planning system
to arbitrate upon that impact
in the context of any benefits that
accrue from the proposal
this matter i think it is essential to
first
place the proposed development into its
proper context
briefly the club is located within the
village not on an exposed extremity
there is no objection in principle from
cpre
there is no impact upon nearby
residential properties no objection from
the eho
and with regard to the issue of
reflected light that has been covered by
the eho in the
update you've received today heritage
and archaeology have both been covered
by detailed and separate reports by
appropriately qualified specialists
it's a bit disappointing that having
requested these and insisted upon the
use of
separate specialists they haven't been
peer reviewed by
specialized people on behalf of your
council but the key thing is that
there's no
specialist objections by on either
archaeology or heritage
the lights are as low as is reasonable
to be effective and remove light seepage
and the committee must not be mistaken
into thinking that these lights will
will be on for extended periods
it's not the case the application
requests a cut off at 9 30 pm weekdays
and we would accept
an earlier cutoff during evenings and
they will
only light each court when that quarters
in use
the lights will be low rise and we'll
also have negligible
visual intrusion the benefits that must
be taken into account
are the strong and well established
policy of your council
supporting and actively encouraging
participation within sports
sports being beneficial to physical and
mental health and well-being
and the club has worked hard to maintain
and encourage its membership to have a
future though
it has to retain and develop that
membership particularly upon
younger and family memberships and
members will not be retained if there is
no opportunity to play social and match
tennis
and coach in the evenings without
lighting it will become what it is at
present just a daytime and weekend
facility between late autumn and early
spring
sport england and the lta have provided
unequivocal support
recognizing in particular benefit of
catching youngsters early in the
their career thank you chair thank you
committee
i am here to answer any questions if i
can
mr roberts i think that was perfect
timing well done um
okay any questions from the committee
please thank you so we've got
uh council jennings first place
thanks chairman so i just want a little
bit of clarification on this
is it grass or hardcores hardcore
it is hardcore yeah okay thank you very
much
okay uh counselor crumb
thank you um just so we're 100
clear and i thought i was and
and i've had this confirmed by legal
officer though um
that there wouldn't be any flood
lighting at the weekends
not i mean what the suggestion is
nothing beyond 6 30.
but i have to but i have to say if your
committee um
felt that uh it should they should not
not be on at the weekends
then i'm sure the um club would accept
that
thank you that yep thank you very much
good point
and uh final question from councillor
dixon please
thank you chairman uh mr robinson uh
regarding how the
the lights are going to be as it were
turned on and off
obviously the report indicates that they
can be on a timer to end at 9
30. i wonder whether it's a situation
whereby
when players start playing on the court
do they actually have to
as it were put the money in the slot set
it for one hour
two hours whatever therefore could there
be an opportunity where it might run
over
if there is time left and it might be
automatically then turning itself off
when the money runs out at say 950.
uh no i can um my own club has the has
uh seven floodlit courts and um
i can tell you exactly how they uh they
operate there is a cut off point so it
doesn't matter if you
put your money in at 9.25 they're like
you get five minutes worth of light
they cut off at 9 30. but and
and the other point i was trying to make
is that i don't want the committee to
think that
these lights will be on every night
until 9 30.
they're only on because they're not
cheap for members to use
you put the money in you book a slot and
i can assure you as a
somebody who does this you only put the
lights on when you want to use them
because they're not cheap so they will
only be on
when used and there will be times for
midweek
and i'm sure there will be times when um
if the weather's in clements for example
there will be the lights will not be on
at all thank you
nobody will be playing that's perfect
thank you very much
um i don't see any further questions
appearing in the chat
so in that case i think mr robinson all
we need to do is thank you for your time
tonight
appreciate it thank you thank you
okay that's all of our uh questions and
some of our speakers
dealt with um we moved them to points of
clarification from the committee does
anybody have any questions
counselor jennings you can kick up off
you go
thank you chairman so it's a question
obviously
amy the lights in that people have been
saying the different heights of lights
um
in claverden um and they're saying that
there could be seven meters or whatever
um
do you know what sort of height at the
other these other
floodlights are at
okay thank you councillor um i i don't
know um
what the other heights of of the other
lights are um
but what i can do is i can show you some
um screen grabs of
um the pub which is very near to the
application
site and also um the rugby club which
um obviously isn't isn't near to the to
where the um
application site is in relation to
obviously the pub so if i just share my
screen i can share that with you
so um the red lion pub can you see my
screen sorry
i can indeed okay so the red lion pub um
i have a screen grab of
there which i can show you um so this is
from the road side where you can see
obviously the the light which has been
referred to
um and then if i go to um the rugby club
which isn't within the conservation area
and isn't obviously within sort of the
immediate location
of the application site um i don't know
if you can see but in the distance you
can just see
some poles um and that's that is
that the lights but as i say i don't
know what size they are or their heights
okay here's the pub in the conservation
area
um yeah so this is where the pub is
yeah and the application site is here
there aren't any buildings to the right
of
it's open countryside um so
the pub is here and this is the pub car
park and then you have open countryside
beyond
okay that's great thank you very much
thank you our next question is
councillor mills
thanks mr chairman um amy the uh
floodlights are 6.2 meters high or
near as 6.12 meters high absolutely
um and the ground is raised is it
as well so that lifts them up a little
bit more does it yeah
so if i share my screen with you again
um i'm not
aware of what the actual height
difference is um but this
image probably shows you most clearly
where you can see the road level
um on church road and then you can see
the height then of the tennis courts
above so
so the land slopes up towards um the
tennis court thank you if i may another
question
mr chairman um the closest residential
um building where would that be to the
proposed tennis floodlights okay can you
see my screen counselor
okay okay yes so we have residential um
to the south so this is wheel right so
this was the
white um rendered um property you could
see
in the images um and then obviously you
have residential then
um all adjacent to the eastern side the
other side of the um
the road and and how far are they away
with props or
approximately bear with me um so i've
done this from the
the actual edge of of the tennis court
so
if we take um forge end which is this
property here so going from
the the most eastern point of the
application site
it's approximately 22 meters if we take
wheel rights which is to the south um to
the near edge of the court
um sorry the application site red edge
it's approximately 10.3 meters
and so and sorry miss gem and no hedges
in between
so if i go back to my site photos um
so so this is from within this site so
this is um the neighboring property real
whites and then we have forge end here
and then obviously adjacent properties
so this hedgerow runs along um the
immediate boundary with both um park
drive
and church road and these images are
taken from
so this one is from church road um
and this image is looking down park
drive so this is
wheel rights and this is forge end and
the tennis courts are
the other side of this hedge wonderful
thanks ever so much amy thank you that's
okay thank you
right i don't see any further points of
clarification in the chat appearance so
i'll presume uh members were ready to go
to the debate
so who would like to start is it
don't all rush at once of course
thank you councillor jennings over to
you
okay well my initial thoughts on this
sir and then
when you i certainly feel for the people
who live around
next to this tennis court um
when you when you move to an area or a
town like claverden
and there are no street lights
and you you probably expect
that there aren't going to be street
lights or flood lights
um shining light into your house all the
time
um at the moment i'm sort of
i'm with the officer on this one um
if it was if the lights were lower
it probably i i
may be inclined to change my mind but uh
it looks like that the 6.12
meters and it's raised up so you're
looking at about seven meters
possibly um it seems
seems awfully high but obviously when we
you can't condition it that it's i'm
presuming that it's
you can only go to five meters or four
and a half meters
um because the application is
in for 6.12 meters so we have to base it
on what's in front of us
i mean if it was if it was lower i say
that like the pub down the road um or
not the one of them which was four
meters high under the eaves
um yeah four meters reasonable that
hedge
looks like it would um it would cover
the something which is four meters high
it's seven meters high
those lights are going to be shining
over the hedge um
i don't know whether you can condition
that you're not allowed to cut the hedge
you have to grow the hedge or
it starts getting very complicated and
it's not what it's not what we're here
to decide
um the pub down the road the red lion
there their lights again it's hard to
tell how high they are but
those they're not pointing towards any
houses um
it's on the a4189
and it's pointing so you're not shining
light into it into a house you've got
the pub in the way so those are my
thoughts and inclinations at the moment
thank you council jennings um
council mills you said question i
presume you sort of comment on the
debate
i'm sorry mr i mean comment sorry yes go
for it
um yes i think the um
the council's put up a good argument for
the
um the lights but
we have almost exactly the same
situation
in kindeston where we have got uh our
tennis courts
uh lit up in the evening you know early
evening
and i have to say the light pollution is
awful even now
it was it caused a great deal of angst
with um
with neighbours um as much as i
sympathize with the parish council
and with simon i i i think i'll have to
go with the officer's recommendation on
this one mr chairman thank you
thank you council mills uh our next
question
council dixon thank you chairman
i'm tending to uh go in the uh the
opposite direction
um i can certainly see the benefit in
enabling sport all the year round
which is what uh would obviously be an
option
and a possibility i also see a situation
whereby this
club is not that necessarily um
strongly supported and therefore the
likelihood
of the lights being on each evening each
night etc during the week
i think is indeed minimal and if the
club was to expand
such that the light became an issue it
would really be
quite a a change in that particular
club's environment
um obviously we can't control the hedge
it's not in the ownership of
the tennis club or in the control of the
tennis club
uh light spillage to the neighboring
properties well
modern lighting and uh the opportunities
of buffers and the light can control the
light
to ensure it stays on the court and in
the immediate surrounds
so i don't see the light being a problem
to neighboring properties
essentially ultimately it's a question
of the dark skies
i can recall a long time ago my very
first planning meeting
was when a development at henley was
objected to by many many local residents
and uh it was actually agreed for the
school there
to have the sports ground one of the
early meetings we had
uh last year when i returned was the
situation whereby
was rugby club was starting to take over
and the whole of henley were objecting
to that because they were going to lose
their sports facilities
which initially they totally objected to
having in the first place
um so people's opinions do change over
time
um i'm minded to think that we could be
uh
supporting a tennis club and the young
people of cleveland
thank you councillor dixon um councillor
curtis please
thanks um i must admit yes i
feel really ambivalent about this i can
see all the advantages of encouraging
young people
i just wondered if there's anybody in
the committee who has any idea of what
the actual costs of you know of using
this hard because
um reference was made to you know you
wouldn't you wouldn't be putting
five quid in the machine if you only
only had five minutes left
to run i don't does anybody have any
idea of the actual costs
for players
there may be an argument if if this is
to encourage a lot of young people to
use
these facilities that doesn't have any
bearing i didn't find the arguments
about the whole higher
um the the encroachment on weddings at
all convincing i must say
um and i think i i think i would agree
with
councillor dixon on this i'd be sort of
minded to come down marginally in favor
of granting
that's great thank you couch for coaches
um we'll move
the councillor crump now please
i think um i think i'm on the same side
of the net as
councillor dixon and councillor curtis
at the moment
um
um there's several issues i'm
i must have i've known my callers to the
mast that
i've always been brought up with sport
i've always had associations with sport
on i'm treasurer of surf and cricket
clubs to our diploma
um many many health issues that can be
sorted out by playing sport
we already know there's a potential
obesity problem in younger children
there's the mental health issue that
younger children are going through at
the moment as well and sport is a great
relaxant and gets them away from in the
fresh air and gets
them uh gets them you know running
around an activity and takes their mind
off
that the pressures they're under both at
work and at bath at school
and also in their in their with their
peers
um you also get a set of values
installed by being part of the club
being part of the team and thinking
about other people as well
those values last throughout your life
and some of those
that i've learned have done you also get
to meet other people
so if you're going from a primary school
to a senior school
you see other people there and you've
got a different peer group you've got
some friendships established
but we're talking about the green
emergency and sustainability in our
climate
um why use why encourage people to go
10 15 miles to other facilities
um that catch the launch mentioned
when there's there's something there as
well um and there's something say
the only other flood facility i believe
according to council thornton i might be
wrong so i apologize
is is the rugby one but and not all
children want to play rugby
you know um so therefore providing an
alternative
would be acceptable so i'm in favor of
the application
um again if we clarify the points
regarding weekend floodlits um
in the in the evenings you know i would
i would go with the 9 30
as mentioned by the parish council and
no flood that
weekend evenings and i'd be happy to uh
support
the uh go against officers
recommendation
and a grant this one so
councillor crump is that a formal um
proposal or not i'm just trying to work
out if there is one there
yeah i um yeah i'm happy to uh propose
that we
we grant this application okay thank you
for that counselor
um i've got uh councillor jennings
asking to comment again please
yes sorry i think um counselor pete
peter hench seraphin hasn't spoken yet
and knowing he wants to speak i'll let
him go first
okay that's fine go for it thank you
yeah i've i've listened to both
arguments quite seriously and uh
i think uh we must retain
sports for young people and i'm uh
on the side of granting this application
thank you okay thank you
i'll connect to james
of course that young people can still
play tennis there
i mean most of the year um it's light
and most of the time when people go and
play tennis it's
often seen as a as a summer sport and
uh you don't need from sort of
april may onwards until
september or so you don't need
floodlights it's only
it's only in the winter that you need
floodlights and
quite frankly it's freezing cold and
probably raining
i don't know how much use it's going to
get but sort of i mean sport is great
but you're imposing your sport
um on other people by the floodlights
there
if it would say the floodlights were
lower and it wasn't impacting on the
people in the surrounding area so
i'd be more inclined to change my mind
but on this one
to me is it's too high um
i'm happy to make a formal proposal that
we go with the officer's recommendation
on this one and refuse the application
thank you council jennings well we'll
have to take them in order in the order
in which they've been
focused obviously so i've got councillor
dixon saying he's happy to second
council dixon
yes i'm i'm happy to second the uh
proposal by councillor crump
um the regarding uh
what councilor james has just been
saying yes um
if the uh tennis is most used in the
summer there's no need for lighting to
be on in the summer in fact it won't
be on so there's no issue there
regarding nuisance
in the winter if it's cold and wet they
won't be on so again not a great deal of
use etc
so the amount of light spillage and the
amount of time that these
lights will actually be on causing uh
a loss of dark skies which is where i
would be coming from
i think will be very minimal indeed so i
would definitely
be supportive of this and grant so i'm
very happy with the second
right okay uh councillor crump you've
indicated like one more
uh response
councillor dixon has answered my comment
was
he's about to catch legends and again um
i would say that some people do need
next year we all get
season adjusted disease sad from from
october till january february and we do
need some incentives to
get up and get outside and do something
rather than just sit in front of the
the log fire or the or whatever the
gas fire and get out and this wood again
is encouraging people
to get out and about so and again the
points about
you know in the summer it can be like
till
10 o'clock um in in june
june and july so um again i think the
argument
is okay and i i think the like pollution
there would be some i
agree but i think it's acceptable in
terms for the
the benefit the wider benefit to our
health and
local people and making ensure
a i've got to say this point here a club
remains viable and sustainable because
things have got to change i
did see one comment that they haven't
had full of lights for 33 years why do i
need wouldn't know but
things have changed who would have
thought 12 months ago would have been
sat here in front of a
a virtual meeting instead of meeting
that elizabeth so
we've got to adapt you've got to evolve
and then and people have different
things in their lives so sometimes at
night is the only time they can do these
things so
that's just my point really thank you
thank you uh councilman
uh alice um i think council trump has
actually
started put together his reasons for
grant there are you content with those
but i think basically it's the benefit
outweighs the harm i think really
thank you thank you chairman i think i
think that was exactly what i sort of
wanted to understand i think
what i've noted down really is that the
um the the views that councillor crump
has
put forward is that the health benefits
and sort of encouragement of local
sports provision
represents such a benefit to presumably
outweigh the harm which has been
identified in the report
so just so i understand a member's
mindful that the is uh it that it
doesn't preserve the openness of the
green belt and that there is harm's
heritage assets and that there is harm
to the landscape but that the benefits
constitute either very special
circumstances in the green belt
or benefits sufficient to outweigh the
harm to heritage assets and the
landscape harm that's probably something
i'd just like to clarify
i think i think i'm getting a lot of
nods from around the around the room
virtual room so i think yes we can we're
satisfied with that
i suppose can i just come back danny
sorry
yeah it conforms with um crabadon's ndp
policy
and i suppose we could also try to say
making it making
the club more sustainable
as in terms of income generation
throughout the year
and we're also trying to it might be
slightly tenuous so this so tell me if
it is
that we're making a contribution by
encouraging people to
remain local to play their sport
rather than travel 10 to 15 miles
uh to go to other places that have got
floodlights
well through you chair i think they're
all sort of cumulatively together
um i think a representative of the the
public benefits that members are minded
to
to give more weight to than the harms
identified uh by the officer
um so yes well i'm satisfied with that
in terms of taking forward to a vote i
think that as ross has picked up whether
we want to sort of agree
conditions prior to going to a vote
chair
that's perfect so alice i was going to
say i'm sure there's a set of standard
conditions that come with this but the
one i think that
i really want to hammer out now will be
uh times a day of usage for this so
if i just put it out there and we'll see
if all members are happy i would suggest
weekdays are cut off at nine o'clock
and weekends cut off at six o'clock for
the hours of use
and i i'm getting a lot of thumbs up if
anybody wildly disagrees shake your
heads at me now or indicate in the chat
but i'm i'm happy with that conditions i
think lovely okay
for the record everybody is every time
everyone seems happy with that
okay right i'm aware that we have a
second
a proposal as well i think we should put
this first one to the vote
and see what happens before returning to
the second proposal
um right let's get to it uh let's start
the vote
uh councillor kendall uh full
thank you councillor crump
that's the front four the curtis
because it's four councillor dixon
councillor dixon four that's a hunter
seraphin
okay so anxious everything for
councillor jennings council jennings
against
councillor mills council mills against
yeah that's five four and two against
that's excellent okay therefore the
committee resolves to grant application
reference
uh nineteen slash zero three four eight
two slash f u l alice you want to just
clarify the conditions on that
yes please so in terms of the lighting
one i think we've covered that so
um lights operate operational
until 9 pm on weekdays 6 p.m on weekends
i think the other ones that we're
reminded to attach and i'd just like to
get sort of
a nod from you that you're happy with
standard
three-year implementation um
in accordance with the approved details
which will include the data pack which
has the specifications of the lighting
um a third condition to require details
of the color material design of the
baffles to be installed on the lights
and then finally that lighting condition
lighting condition can i just confirm
that
occurs absolutely that's what i meant
when i said i know you have a standard
set of conditions that don't work
that's fine thank you thanks chad okay
let's then move to our next application
that's item
5 found on page uh 29 of your agendas
uh this that is application reference
twenty slash
zero three one three two slash l b
c and is for avon caro lower end dave
and dacid
this is the retention of a conservatory
uh with heating flu
um and an additional alteration to the
roof and design
uh i'm getting a moment that we just
need to pause for a second to bring in
our speakers hold on a second
apologies told you i was gonna be
slightly rusty at this tonight
just give you a moment liz
right okay let's go live again apologies
for that
right i'll just wait for that we do have
our speaker
in the meeting as well so that's
excellent so we're ready to move on uh
quick
uh recap this is then twenty slash zero
three one three two slash lbc
four caro lower uh haven caro lower and
okay presenting officer is robert parker
robert are you ready to go on this one
yes okay i'll just
just open my presentation
you can see that perfect
[Music]
okay can everyone hear me and see the
presentation
see everything here everything over to
you okay thank you um
just to remind everyone this application
is for the retention of
out and alterations to a conservatory at
four even carro
even does it uh this slide
shows that the application site lies to
the southeast
end of the village adjacent to the
countryside
the site also lies within the avendasset
conservation area
the application site is outlined in
black
and includes a one and a half story
dwelling with garden
which is located on the north western
side of the grade two listed
avon carroll complex
this slide shows the sight in 1904 on
the left
with an update up-to-date aerial photo
of the complex
today as you may be able to pick out the
main features
are a courtyard plan
a central gateway
which views down along treed avenue
a service range to the rear which
included
the old kitchen and stables and coach
house
the principal range is on southwestern
side these included the main
rooms principal rooms large rooms um
it had a large spacious setting
a fairly open type landscape
with no partitioning
it was previous to the house
an area of open fields with hedges
this slide shows historic examples from
the early 16th century
uh one one will be familiar to everyone
hampton court top
left and below it
the more local cotton court
these are from the tudor period where
the the country became more stable and
wealthy and everyone alluded
to a fortified castle uh they wanted to
show their
their wealth um and they wanted to show
something familiar from the past
to reflect their status
the style absorbed in renaissance
influences and looked back to the
medieval fortified house
allude into a state of defense and power
defining characteristics include
battlements symmetry
defensive looking outer walls and a
dominating
central gateway the example
top right is leeds castle and this was
built in 1823
and demonstrates the continuing romantic
association
with the past uh and the
um uh
the need i suppose of people to
demonstrate their power and
on their wealth um bottom right
outlined in red this is evan carroll and
you can see the similarities
even caro was built in the 1890s a
period when
two architecture was highly influential
and fashionable
it is obvious that even cairo adopted
such
adopted such early examples and models
as illustrated around the photograph
perhaps the owner was attracted to their
symbolism and influence at the time
these slides show views of the courtyard
the first is looking back
to the principal domestic range whilst
the second looks out
east looks out towards the service
ranges
the photos demonstrate the high standard
of the design
and quality of craftsmanship
it's also clear that the the composition
has
changed very little and there's a sense
of cohesion
slide 6 shows the existing conservative
design in the top left hand corner
the drawing to the right illustrates the
proposals to clad the conservatory with
a lead roof
and a timber base to try and make the
composition
a bit more solid and responsive to the
background
the framework color is also to be
changed and this is to be agreed
perhaps by condition
this sheet shows the conservative
close-up and from a distance in the
property's garden
as you can see the conservatory is made
up of
colored brown colored plastic with a
palastic
plastic corrugated type roof
um the original building is obviously in
the background and is made up
of slate and local iron stone
this final slide shows the neighboring
properties and the remaining facade to
the north
east of note is the unextended facade
and cohesion of authentic design which
defines the historic
envelope it is recommended in this case
that listed billing consent be refused
for reasons outlined within the officer
report
thank you
thank you for that robert okay we go to
our
first speaker that's leslie kipling the
applicant
are you there by any chance can you just
uh hello chair yes i am here thank you
lovely stuff
well thank you for waiting so patiently
you have three minutes to speak uh if
you remain on the line at the end of
that three minutes for any questions the
committee may have
and we'll give you a warning for the
last 30 seconds is that okay
lovely thank you over to you then okay
good evening everybody
why am i here addressing you on my
wedding anniversary
well that's because i asked my friend to
look after our chickens whilst we were
away
after returning we had a letter to say
we had been reported for having an
illegal conservatory
we were shocked because of the betrayal
of a friend which really hurts
especially as she lives in avon carrow
and has a conservatory before we erected
our small conservatory we first spoke to
the council who advised us that planning
permission
was not required we found out that
listed planning consent
was needed and we submitted our
application
hopeful that it would be favorably
received bearing in mind the structure
only measures eight foot by ten foot and
trust me there are bigger garden sheds
in the carrow
it is affixed to the wall through four
screws
only through the mortar not the stone
the same as would be used for two
hanging baskets
the structure freestands on a small part
of a slabbed patio
there are no other foundations it is
sealed to stop drafts with insulation
pushed into the gap
which can easily be removed without any
damage
the boiler flue that has recently been
mentioned has they've been there for
over 20 years
a new boiler and flu was installed by a
corgi registered contractor
in 2018. in our application there is a
detailed heritage report that addresses
all of the councils and the inspector's
concerns
when par robert parker gulliford
inspected
originally he said i am minded to let
you keep it
and yet it was still refused once
erected
it quite simply changed our lives the
house is warmer which has helped our
lung problems
our gp has confirmed this in his letter
which is also included in our
application
suddenly we have space for a dining
table we no longer eat with trays on our
laps
we have entertaining space for our
family and friends
and i have a hobby room for sewing and
painting
the past year has been very difficult
for everyone especially mentally
this is my sanctuary this is my place
away from the husband
my place to sing at virtual choir and
also recently in this lockdown
i have been caring for our granddaughter
two days a week so it has now become our
school room
i don't honestly know how i would have
got through this knock down without it
i would have to sit on the bed trying to
do these things and that would be very
difficult
if we remove it now or later
if we it will affect nothing there is no
damage
to the building and nobody can see it
who will even know it has gone the only
people that this is going to affect
are martin and i and our quality of life
very little has been made of the 19
comments of support
of which 12 are caro residents we have
applied for temporary permission as we
feel that this is a common sense
solution
we have gone so far as to a section 106
agreement or a unilateral undertaking to
dismantle at the end of the term
or if we should leave the property
earlier
also included in the inspectors report
i cannot express how much this little
thank you sorry mr kipling i hope you
can still hear me your time has elapsed
i'm just going to ask for the committee
to
put any questions in the chat see if
they do
there we go that's fantastic thank you
councillor jennings you have a question
just thank you very much just uh just so
i got this completely straight in my
mind
that the french doors were there before
and you've just added on
the plastic conservatory um
to the outside as in i you didn't knock
down a wall and put in a lintel and then
build the conservatory
ms kipling if you'd like to click uh i
think star and six to unmute so you can
answer the question please
i'm not sure mrs um can you can you
still hear me please
click start i press star and six twelve
news
can i can i chip in and
oh here we are there you go can you hear
did you hear our question for you
sorry yes um no we didn't break through
the wall
uh it was already here the french doors
were here when my husband moved in over
20 years ago
we respect the carrow we love living
here and we wouldn't damage the building
for anything
that's great thank you for that are
there any other further questions
from the committee the peer to peer
thank you very much for your time
tonight it's much appreciated uh you're
you're free to hang out now and continue
watching on the live stream
thank you thank you church bye-bye
okay uh we go to our ward member who's
registered to speak on this tonight
council fielding
thank you chair you have five minutes
you know the you know the routine
i'll be rewarding it uh the last 30
seconds
i'm hope before i start could you bring
up the plan showing the numbering system
and the
there's one that um we've got photos on
the screen now
now there's one which actually shows
where all the properties are anyway i'll
go ahead
uh i'm in sport of the scheme as the
lean-to unit is small
it has minor impact on both the visual
and the structural effect on the caro
i'll start by referring to the core
strategy cs1
refers to when considering a development
the council
will take a positive approach that will
reflect the presumption in favor of
sustainable development
contained in the nppf
cs5 visual impact of the proposed
depends on the scale
and use and location cs8
historical environment where a
development proposal
will lead to less and substantial harm
to the significance
of a designed heritage asset this harm
will be justified
and weighed against public benefit for
the proposal
including securing the optimum of
viable use in the inspector's report
he referred to the fact that
the fact that um appreciates that the
conservatory leaned to
provides additional living accommodation
and social benefits
for the applicant and as such space has
been
particularly of benefit during the
pandemic i also know the
energy efficient benefits of the
structure
and the subsequent benefit to the
applicant's health
energy efficiency is supported by the
council and the pandemic it will be with
us for a number of years
the information i'm now referring to
comes from the consultant used by the
property owners
richard k morris he is a historical
building consultant
and has been working with english
heritage in the crown estates amongst
other institutions
the conclusion to his report is that the
physical impact
of such of just four screws holding the
lean-to
in place prevents any otherwise gap
between the unit and the
listed wall it is considered that whilst
the lean
two may not endure it
enhance it the significant harm to the
listed building
that could be accrued is negligible and
at the end
at the lowest end of the less
of the substantial harm spectrum
lord justice lewisen at the appeal court
stated it is clear that as a matter of
both of law
and planning policy that harm if it
exists
it is to be measured against both the
scale of the harm
and the significance of the heritage
asset although the statutory duty
requires special regard
to be paid to the desirability
of not only harm harming the setting of
a listed building
that cannot be cannot mean that any harm
however minor should necessarily require
planning permission to be refused in
1908 the building was divided up into 16
units
and with their own garden over the last
40 years have been various developments
by the individual owners
which create different garden designs
and associated structures these have
included
sheds one large summer house and in the
garden of number six
and a large conservatory belonging to
number nine
can we have that picture up please it's
number four
this is a two-bedroom two-story property
situated on the north side of the
building this unit comprises an upstairs
master bedroom and box
room on the ground floor there is a
living room with kitchen
gallery kitchen the property is drafty
and is not suitable for an
elderly couple in poor health this was
stated
in the inspectors report they have the
support of 12 of their fellow
occupiers of the carrow and the
immediate neighbor
number 16 who looks overlooks their
garden
hasn't even noticed it many listed
historical properties have
conservatories
and and it is not unknown for the listed
property
to have a lien to of such large
proportions
i must remind you of lord lewisham's
judgment
that cannot mean that any harm however
minor
would necessarily require planning
permission to be refused
i rest my case
thank you very much councillor fielding
do we have any questions for the ward
member please indicate in the chat
let's have a look i think you're gonna
get off light there i'm not seeing
anything appear excellent okay dave er
capsule connectors apologies councillor
curtis has a question
thank you it was just a question of
clarification
um please cancel the fielding the we saw
a photo
um with two cars in the front there's
that
i can best describe it that showed um
another part of the property with a
conservatory
belonging to number nine and it's
visible from the public highways that's
a large
conservatory there right do you can do
you know how long that
has been there i don't because i believe
the listing of this property happened in
1987 and i think it was
probably up in 1988 or thereabouts but
that is definitely what i really wanted
to clarify that is definitely
a different property with the
conservatory on it but very much
thank you very much for the
clarification thank you chair
thank you uh councillor jennings that
was exactly my question as well
it was going through my head as well
good question obviously
um okay if there are no further
questions well i think i think there are
no further questions we'll say thank you
very much councillor fielding for his
time this evening
and we can move to uh points of
clarification
to the officers anybody have any
questions for the officers
councillor mills you were first in there
over to you how about that
uh thanks mr um robert the
um uh the conservatory
we're looking at at the moment is that
normally permitted on allowed under
permitted development
yes it does not require planning
permission if if it was
free standing uh like a shed then it
would need planning permission
and not listed billing consent so in
this case it just needs a list of
billing consent
lovely thank you okay councillor crump
you have a question
it was a comment on so okay apologies
yeah that's okay councillor jennings do
you have a question
yes thank you robert um just a quick
coin
here we've it's been brought up in uh
this
conservatory on number nine and i know
it doesn't
every playing application has to be
joshua's own merit
but um there seems to be one at number
nine
do you know anything about it um yes
that that one
sorry sorry why was that allowed
um it was approved in 1988
um the building was listed in 1987.
um the the first policy
that plan authorities followed was
brought out in 1987 before that there
was very little guidance so i'm not too
sure when stratfor took on conservation
officers but
the the expertise has developed quite
rapidly since 1987 uh and the way we
deal with things now is slightly
different to the way things are dealt
with
um in the mid 80s so i think the problem
here is that
we're trying to get consistency we've
had two
appeals that dismissed conservatories
and the council in the past is approved
to
um one was also approved at number 16
in 2006 but that's expired and as far as
we know
um no part of it has commenced so that
that's extant
sorry that's expired so
the only conservatory or president is
relevant is number nine but as i say
that was approved in 1988
soon after new policy on conservation
was brought out in 87
and since then an appeal
for one at number 11 further along
was dismissed in 2002 and we've had
the recent case for number four where
the conservative conservatives dismissed
it appeal
so i think what we're trying to say is
that
this is an important distinctive
building it's not just the insights
important but also the outside we're
trying to protect the cohesion
and unity of the original design we
appreciate it's been subdivided
and there are many gardens around it but
it
remains more or less unaltered on the
outside
it is in looking and outward looking it
has a courtyard but it also has
an outward context so
hopefully that explains some of the
backgrounds basically the one at number
nine got away with it
um no they haven't got away with it they
got permission
but i think it was viewed differently
even the inspector's decision
for number 11 which was dismissed
accepted that the one at number nine was
a different context
it was a different relationship i don't
i think it's because it was decision
approved so long ago if we wanted to
take a different decision
it's it's it doesn't carry that much
weight
i think what does carry lightweight are
the two appeals that we have that were
dismissed
okay councilman are you satisfied with
the answer
yep thank you very much thank you uh are
there any other points of clarification
uh pause for a second the chat looks
quiet
so let's go to the debate does anybody
want to kick off on this
so just to get an idea here that if they
would get rid of this
uh conservatory and they would
possibly be able to build a big cabin
like the one couple of doors down
so had to have that extra space there if
they were
i wasn't going to address it but now
it's being raised that the cabin you saw
on the photograph we've gone right
no record of planning patient being
granted for that
so really we have to look at that and
see why it's gone up
not for this committee meeting no
um sorry does that answer the question
or was there more to the question
no no that answers that okay okay
that's good thank you right council
mills you've indicated you'd like to
comment
in the debate this time are we we're in
the debate thanks mr chairman
yeah i seem to remember this um
i mean you seem to remember this has
come to us before hasn't it this um
some time ago um sorry
yeah yeah i think yes there was there
was an application
but it it was refused under delegated
powers it didn't go to planning
committee um
yeah and they were yeah um
it i'd say it's not it's not the
prettiest of um
of conservatives but it's not doing this
for my mind tremendous amount of harm
and it is giving the people
um probably that little bit of extra
space they do need
um and it is
oil intensive temporary isn't it because
it sits into the water
and can be pulled down at a time so i'm
i'm minded to um
to grant this uh applications chairman
thank you
thank you councillor mills uh councillor
jacks
i think this is this has failed twice at
appeals
um and whilst
it does there is minor harm here um
we've still got to come up with valid
material planning reasons
why we could i would
go with it um i don't know what they are
at the moment
um minor harm possibly but
um i say that the fact that it's gone to
appeal
had two appeal decisions um go against
it
says something and the fact
that every single house there could now
put up one of these
and say well you know it's minor harm
but eventually
sort of it is creating harm um
i wish there was a better solution for
the people who live there
um and that's why i asked about
the if they could take it down and build
something else in their garden
like the other one and therefore gain
gain the space back there
um but obviously that doesn't look as if
that that's a
goer either um
so don't particularly like it but uh
at the moment i'm probably gonna have to
go with the officer's decision on this
simply because
i don't see a valid reason to go against
him
thank you councillor jennings um
councillor dixon would like to comment
thank you chairman uh yes i'm uh tending
to agree with councillor jennings on
this one
um i see a situation here whereby um to
go against the two appeals would be
very difficult indeed and certainly if
we were minded to
to grant uh permission then i could only
see
a situation whereby each property uh
decides to put a conservatory on the
rear of its uh facade
admittedly it wouldn't be going into the
courtyard but it would be going on to
the listed building
um i might be wrong but uh i would
understand or believe that if the
occupants wanted to have a summer house
of reasonable size they would simply
need to have
uh consent because it would then be
within the cartilage of a listed
building
as opposed to actually requiring listed
building
consent i can stand correct by more
means robert if that is not the case
uh but i think we need to go along with
the officer's recommendation on this one
um yes if they want a free styling
structure they need planning permission
and then we start looking at the setting
of this
building but it's possible that if you
come up with something perhaps in scale
it's gardenesque then that might be we
might be more favorable towards that
than than adding things onto the outside
of the building
thank you robert thank you both
okay and next we have a councillor
curtis
thanks um i really support
um councilman mills position on this i
think really
it does seem looking at the back
gardens of those various properties um
they're hardly beautiful clean
lines it seems a right hot potch
of large sheds small sheds
all sorts of different manner of
outbuildings
there is this um the existing
um conservatory built on the back of
number nine and i
it is a balance i can't imagine that if
this were granted suddenly
every uh property would suddenly be
putting conservatives on onto their back
gardens and i
i'd support cats and meals if there is a
way of
finding a reason to support it then i
would be in
in favor of doing so but that may not be
possible
thank you thank you councillor curtis
um right well i'm conscious that we not
anybody else line up speak and we've not
yet got a proposal um
i'll add my thoughts at this point as
i think what people said council dixon i
think council jennings
you're both right i i can't i can't find
that reason to allow this and we've got
to look at those most recent appeal
decisions and
they go against this so i have i have
i feel very sorry for the applicants and
i think you know they've been
you know a slightly raw deal on this one
um and i can understand them feeling
justifiably
annoyed and upset and all of that but i
have to support the offices on this i
think
the officers made the correct
recommendation to refuse
so i'm going to propose um that we
refuse this application i'll
ask and see if anybody would like to
come in and second me
on that
first thing
i'm not sure if that's come through but
i've seconded it oh it's not come
through here sorry it must be a lag so
thank you council
captain james so that's proposed and
seconded there um
let's see given that i'm having to lag
on the chat end of this is
there anyone else wishing to comment at
this point does anybody else want to say
anything
before i go to a vote because my
chat doesn't seem to be working at home
just to chip in
okay nobody wants to speak so let's go
to the vote on this then okay olivia
so i've refused the application for the
reasons stated in the report
councillor kendall four thank you
councillor cramp
that's the crump against that's the
curtis
councillor curtis against councillor
dixon
councillor dixon four jennings
council jennings four and councillor
mills
yeah that's three four and three against
three four three against excellent right
well that is my casting decision as the
chairman tonight so
i will uh uphold what i said before so
um
yes i i vote my casting vote
to refuse uh to refuse the application
uh so with that uh the uh
the committee uh resolved to refuse
application twenty slash
zero three one through two slash lbc
for the reasons stated uh we'll pause
for a second to get the next speakers in
please
liz
howdy
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hello
okay
hello hello hello there i believe
we have our speakers in thank you both
if you just uh
pause for a second we'll just restart
the meeting
thank you
all right you can commence again then
like we have all of our speakers
in there with me i'm having a few
technical hitches with um
i believe we have our speakers here
thank you both you
just pause for a second we'll just
restart the meeting
thank you okay
um for those people for any speakers if
you could just
mute yourselves for now please that'd be
fantastic and we can have you unmute in
a moment
otherwise we do get this awkward uh
delay on the line where we end up
hearing ourselves and for me it's most
disconcerting
uh i can't stand hearing myself it's
awful
i feel sorry for all of you having to
listen to me right okay then
so i think we're ready to begin this
application so
um if you bear with me i will read the
application references so
uh we have two applications here for the
same property
uh twenty slash zero two five two four
slash f u
l twenty 02525
lbc uh these four uh alteration
proposed rio single story extension and
alteration to existing dwelling of
mulberry house brooklyn new bolt on
right our presenting officer is
charlotte dix charlotte
are you ready to present yes i am
thank you very much chairman thank you
let me just share my screen with you
right can you see the presentation
absolutely perfectly lovely thank you
very much
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle
the application site is located in
newbord onstar on brook lane
this slide shows the application site
edged in black the property is a grade 2
listed farmhouse
known as previously farmhouse known as
mulberry house
adjacent to the site and immediately to
the south is a grade 2 listed barn
the dwelling and adjacent barn are
shaded in red on this plan
so this is the property and the adjacent
barn along here
residential properties are but the site
to the north and west with properties
also across the road to the north
the rivers tower above the the
rear boundary of the site
this is an application for full planning
permission and listed building consent
for a single story rear extension
the listed building consent also
proposes some internal
and fenestration alterations this slide
shows the elevations and floor plan of
an existing
l-shaped single-story flat reef rear
extension
shown here which measures between
3.61 meters in projection and
8.36 meters along here
from the original rear elevation
this slide shows the proposed elevations
and floor plan
of the proposed rear infill extension
which would
square off the existing l-shaped rear
extension
the extension would project 8.3 meters
in total projection from the original
rear wall being between
8.9 meters and 9.4 meters in width
with a 3.3 meter high flat reef
the extension would be of contemporary
design with materials proposed as render
and stone
this photo shows the existing rear
elevation of the property
with the existing flat reef extension
visible
here the grade 2 listed barn is also
shown on the left hand side of the photo
and this is the patio area
essentially where the rear extension
would be sited
this photo is taken from the patio area
with the listed dwelling now on the left
hand side
of the photo this is taken from where
the infill extension would be positioned
facing north towards the detached shed
and brook lane beyond
this photo is taken from the patio area
facing north towards the adjacent
property
starbank just to clarify there is an
update to the report within the update
sheet relating to trees
and offers a recommendation is to refuse
the applications for full planning
permission and listed building consent
for the reasons and notes which can be
found on pages 43
and 44 of the agenda
thank you very much chairman thank you
that's brilliant thanks charlotte okay
let's go to our first
speaker um this is from uh councillor
gimblet uh from tradington parish
council
uh council giblet are you there you'll
need to press the star
and six to unmute yourself
yes i can thank you excellent welcome
welcome
yes we can hear you welcome councillor
okay thank you very much that's okay so
you have
three minutes if you'd remain uh on the
call at the end of that time for any
questions from the committee
uh we'll give you a warning at the last
30 seconds if that's okay
that's fine i'll keep this fairly short
and sweet over to you
forward um the parish council has
signaled their support this application
on two previous occasions
uh while noting that the dwelling is
great too listed
parish council believe that the
extension will not affect the house in
any shape or form
especially if the l-shaped extension is
already in place
additionally the work cannot be viewed
from the road will not detract from the
setting of the main building
will greatly improve the appearance of
what is already there
and immediate neighbours have given
their support
furthermore in 2008 an application was
approved by the district council
for a two-story extension with a much
larger footprint in the same part of the
plot
although brooklyn is one of the older
parts of the village there is a somewhat
eclectic array of housing developments
and extension
and the extension does not add to or
detract from the setting in any way
the parish council disagrees with the
conclusion initially report that the
work will detract from the listed
dwelling
and detached barnes composition and
special architectural and historic
interest as it is not viewable from the
road and that extension
and the extension is already in place
furthermore we believe the public
interest is served
by the preservation of the main building
which is the owners doing to the form
we believe the conservation officers
view the extension of excessive and
dominate
nearing is in contradiction of an
alternative view in the committee report
that the damage will be less than
substantial in fact we disagree with the
damage being less than substantial and
that we think there will be no
harm and therefore we lend our support
again to this application
that's all i have chairman oh thank you
very much councillor um do we have any
questions
for the parish council please if you'd
like to indicate in the chat
pause for a moment
all looks quiet in that case councillor
uh gimble thank you very much for your
time tonight it's much appreciated if
you want to hang up and continue to
follow proceedings on the um
live stream that's fantastic stay on the
phone if i may because i can't get the
live stream off on my
computer so i'm just listening nice
that's fine as long as you mute yourself
that's okay thank you
um okay we'll move to our next speaker
uh mark wildish agent
uh and edward uh edwin bolton sorry
applicant
are you both there please
hello chair can you hear me hello who's
that
it's mr wildish hello mr wildish do we
have mr bolton there
i presume not uh mr wilder should you
speaking on behalf of you both then
uh no i i was going to speak for
approximately two minutes
and then mr bolton was going to speak
shortly after me
that's all right let's pause for a
second so you can get mr bolton on the
line as well
mr bolson if you can hear me to uh sit
start
star and six i think i can hear you
there i can hear you now thank you
wonderful okay that's fantastic thank
you well
uh in that case you have three minutes
between you uh i'll let you
uh chipping it out when when you know
the right moment is
is it's your time to speak
tongue tied tonight um you have three
minutes between you
um if you remain on the call for any any
questions at the end
over to you then mr wildis thank you
the officers report quotes the mppf and
policy csa where developments that cause
less than substantial harm
to the significance of listed building
should be weighed against the public
benefit
considering the proposed extension is
out of public view and it's a private
dwelling
this is an untenable test nonetheless in
this instance the public interest
is the preservation and enhancement of
the setting of the two listed buildings
for future generations
also with support from the parish
council and the only neighbor who can
see the rear of mulberry house
clearly current public interest is
contrary to officer's recommendation
where this nozzle listed building an 8
metre single story extension
off the back of this house will be
possible under permitted development
rights
and there are multiple examples
throughout the district where
rear extensions exceed the width of the
host dwelling
the existing ugly extension already
extends 8.3 meters off the rear of
mulberry house
and so the officer's concern regarding
the harm caused by the proposed
extension
exceeding the whip of the house is an
existing situation
under the circumstances insufficient
planning balance has been afforded to
this proposal
and that the potential significant
enhancement to the existing listed
building
is being overlooked paragraph 200 of the
nppf states
proposals that preserve those elements
of the setting that make a positive
contribution to the asset
or which better reveal its significance
should be treated favorably
the conservation officers comment that
our proposed design
is creative innovative and of quality
surely confirms compliance with
paragraph 200 of the npps
and enhances the setting of the two
listed buildings suggestions to reduce
how far the extension should come out
into the infill
would not only result in an impractical
internal layout
it would create a staggered extension
that would highlight the detracting
existing extension by leaving it exposed
against ballistic barn
and this would also detract on the
overall quality of the proposed design
in summary harm to both listed buildings
is already being caused by the existing
extension that comes out 8.3 meters
from the back of marbury house our
proposal simply infills and comes out no
further
than the existing and since our design
is acknowledged as being a high quality
it therefore enhances on the existing
and should be approved
thank you bolton
miss falcon you can add anything at this
point
yes thanks so much all for your time
taken to hear our appeal um so
it's compliments uh mark's technical um
aspects and arguments
um just add a few personal perspectives
and i think firstly to reassure that the
last thing you want to do is anything
that detracts from the property
um and the design is such as complement
the original building
such using more glass to reduce the
impact compared to what is presently
there
it does seem generally accepted that the
extension we propose
is a significant improvement on existing
some optati extension
it would rejuvenate property and improve
its environmental credentials
and i think as um chancellor giblet
mentioned um
i'm not sure if you saw it but it is
much more modest modest
than the two-story extension previously
approved
so as mark markuh mentions um
i really i'm new to this one but i
really don't understand
how it is considered to do any harm at
all the original listing
and at the same time it seems
unreasonable to me
to have to defend the public benefit
when it's fully at of public sites
except for our neighbors who have
witnessed support and have the parish
council
thank you thank you great i'll have to
i'll have to stop you there
your time has now elapsed but thank you
very much for that do we have any
questions from the rest of the committee
for either of our two speakers here
i'll wait for a second for the chat to
move to see if there's something there
that the the chat seems to be quiet
unless
i i i i council diction you were typing
i'm not sure i think
my chat is frozen at this end i'm trying
to refresh it but
council dixon what are you typing i was
in cj
um essentially i must admit um
uh mr bolton essentially the there was
comment made that the extension if
approved
would improve and enhance the look of
the building
i have to say um i've we've seen the
photographs showing the existing
extension and i thought myself well if
we'd have seen this application before
the last one it might have come to a
different decision
um because i have to say this uh
existing addition
to the uh listed building looks
horrendous
so i might my minded to know exactly
how it's going to be improved i was
searching for details of materials and
the like
but i couldn't quickly find them can you
illuminate my
my thoughts as to how the extension if
granted
and the existing building will actually
improve the appearance of this
property sure yeah if you can hear me um
yes i'll give you my layperson sort of
perspective on it i mean essentially
we've
asked mark to commission a a really
delicate sensitive um building with
primarily glass work so you can
effectively see as much the original
building as pop
as possible without having
the eyesore of the existing render which
is tired and tatty
also by having the infill it actually
makes for a much cleaner shape
that doesn't impose anything more in the
existing building
so yeah i mean we moved in six years ago
we thought it was half finished we
actually realized then subsequently it
is fully finished
and but still a nicer so we're very keen
to address this and improve the overall
building
thank you thanks could i just
elaborate slightly on that in terms of a
big question for mr bolton or mr wildish
uh in terms of the building materials it
was mentioned that the building
materials would be render and stone
could you just give me speak to that a
little bit for me please i mean from one
perspective
i'm actually relatively flexible on the
point i mean we'll go with what suits
the property best i think
the glass and and render work we thought
was more
consistent with some with some other
aspects of the property
you may see another picture where
there's another extension to the other
to another wing
which has render so we try to carry that
through but to a higher quality than
what's existing
um but we also did like the idea of
stone to fully complement
but mark maybe have more today on the
points
um yeah i mean so certainly in terms of
uh design materials uh the stonework
would be
carefully matched to the existing and
the
proposed render with which largely
conceals the
remnants of the existing um extension
that is left visible
would then be rendered in a high quality
smooth render finish to match still
lightly existing on the rest of the
house
and then that would then bring
consistency through the mixture of the
stone and the render
to then match back in with the existing
house in a much more harmonious manner
okay thank you for that that clears it
up for me
um i'm not seeing any other questions
popping up into the chat
so i think in that case gentlemen i we
can release you from this part of the
meeting
you can either hang up or mute
yourselves and watch on the live stream
it's up to you
thank you both thanks thanks very much
okay uh we don't have a
ward member registered to speak on this
so we can therefore move to points of
clarification
do we have any questions like what's
clarification i'll
yes councillor mills go for it thanks mr
chairman um
could um could i have
another look at the um the photograph of
the
existing building at the moment tonight
yes of course let me just share my
screen thanks charlotte thank you
can you see the existing elevations
there i can um
do not that applies to this application
but
do you know when the first one was
granted the first application
it doesn't matter no that's we're not
relevant to this so
we're just filling in making it square
aren't we
yes so at the moment we've got this uh
single-story flat reef extension which
consists of the kitchen the dining area
and then this utility
and wc which runs alongside the barn
what's being proposed um and as you can
see it's a
flat roof extension and then they're
proposing to yes basically infill the
existing extension just to effectively
square it all
off to create a sitting room area and
kitchen
and then this the kitchen would create a
dining room area and then a gym here
there are some internal alterations as
well such as the shower room and
and alterations to uh to doors as well
thank you
thank you uh charlotte could have a mr
chairman if i
may have a look at the actual photograph
of the
existing
this is the existing rear elevation so
this is the the flat reef extension so
this is the
obviously the section running along the
barn where the utility and wc are
located and then this is where
the kitchen section is and excuse me
and and that
joins on to the help to the dwelling
behind yes
yes so that's the joining to the the
original part of the the property
so they will come through and right
thanks charlotte thank you very much
thank you no problem
thank you thanks cats mills councillor
jennings you have a question
yeah i was just uh it was going to be
along the same lines it's just squaring
off an l
shape i just wanted clarification on
that and there aren't any better
pictures of what it will actually look
like i mean it's a
it's a bit of a shame that the pictures
are
aren't very descriptive
actually if not i mean so but there
aren't so there aren't any definitely
aren't any other pictures there
of what it would look like i've got some
artistic impressions which i could i
should
could show you yes yes but yeah
bear with me a moment
right can you see that ah yes yes i can
so could you zoom in just a little bit
on that section yeah
okay satisfied i think that does help
actually
that certainly helps yes
it helps you see where the render is
where the stone is going to be i think
that's very helpful um okay council
mills you have another question
um charlotte do you put that artist's
impression up again for me please
yes of course bear with me
can you see that yeah thank you well
um that that is completely different to
what has been showing so
is it is it going to be brick or is it
going to be render the
new it's showing as being a mixture of
stone
and render so these sections are render
and these sections here
are going to be stone
right because that does look an
improvement
what was there before okay thank you
very much thank you
okay so if there are no further points
of clarification
i'll pause for a looks quiet
let's move to the debate does anybody
want to start
counselor jennings
until i saw the artist's impression
there
i i was just trying to visualize exactly
what it would look like
when i see the artist's impression um
that to me is a huge improvement on
what's there at the moment
i'm really struggling to see what damage
that
is doing um if anything i just see this
is a huge improvement
um and um as i've said before and other
planning meetings i'm very much in favor
of
interesting forward thinking design
you can mix um
listed buildings and old buildings with
new designs
that to me is a huge improvement that
those are my initial thoughts
thank you thank you for that council
jennings uh council mills
yeah yeah actually he's stolen all my
thoughts there i mean
until i saw that last impression i
thought my goodness me we just got this
you know this awful looking building so
i'm beginning to change my my thoughts a
moment mr chairman
um yeah thank you
thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman um certainly that uh
design concept and the rest of it
totally throws a different uh aspect on
the whole of this application
and i am now going to propose that we
grant permission
and uh see if there's anybody prepared
to second that
well we have uh councillor curtis uh
also uh agreeing with last year's
speakers council
did you want comment for oh he's
seconding do you want to speak to that
counselor curtis
i'm i'm guessing you don't and we also
have councillor jennings is
offering second so we have a proposal
and a second or two grant
um because we have two applications i'm
going to deal with the first one which
is the
ful the full application and we'll come
to the second one afterwards
um right we need to have clear reasons
don't we uh alice
so uh from my listening to your debate
it's the overwhelming feel i think of
most committee that this is actually
uh an improvement will help to i'm
searching for the right words here uh
we'll help to
uh improve this the
existing uh setting of the building and
the setting of the
listed building alice is that enough or
do you do you need to go further we
i'm not sure can i ask you on that yeah
of course
uh no that's fine uh if members are
minded which which i think they are
please correct me if i'm wrong that the
development proposal does preserve
the listed farmhouse as well as the
setting of the
listed barn which adjoins the site then
there's no need to come up with any sort
of public benefits to justify
uh the decisions so i'm taking that you
are satisfied that it preserves that
those buildings and
also essentially improves it in your
view well i think that's exactly where
everyone's coming from on this one
do you have a set of conditions to go
with this
we do yes so um just to run through
those so
in respect of the application for
planning permission we would recommend
the attachment of the standard
three-year
condition the approved plans condition
a materials condition which will include
the requirement to submit a stone sample
just to make sure that it does reflect
the stone on the list of building and
also the details of the design of the
external doors
and windows again just to make sure that
they um
comply with sort of design and high
quality that we did expect from the list
of building
should we leave it at the full now and
then we'll come on to the list of
building in a moment
i think so let's leave it like that
let's go with that one so i
think we've got everything we need then
so members we
because we have two applications for the
same uh house
we need to do them separately so i'm
gonna go with the first one which is the
full application um and that's the one
up to which i've taken the proposal from
councillor dixon has been seconded by
uh councillor curtis um i'll kick us off
on that
uh councillor kendall four thank you
councillor cramp
christopher curtis
curtis four dickson
councillor dixon four councillor
jennings
council jennings four and councillor
mills council mills four
that's unanimous chair okay thank you
the committee therefore resolves to
grant
twenty slash zero two five two four
slash ful we now return to the lbc
list of building consent um i'm
presuming that we're all in
agreement on saying all this so i will
happily propose that one
do i have a second uh i'll second that
gentleman thank you councillor dixon
perfect
um alice in terms of conditions do we
need to add anything there as well as
the same conditions effectively
uh they'll be very similar let me just
check so we'll have the standard three
years
the standard approved plans design of
external doors and windows which we had
on the full
sample plan of the stone which again we
had on the full the only additional one
that we would have on the list of
building
is that we require details of the design
of the two new doorways
internally um which has been agreed
previously with with the applicant
that's fine well that's my proposal uh
to grant uh the
list of building consent it's been
seconded by council dixon in that case
we gotta vote councillor kendall four
thank you councillor grump mr comfort
councillor curtis who is for
cancer dixon council of dixon four but
alice can we
include the color of the render as well
as the
nature of the stone within those
materials please
yes absolutely not be included in the
standard materials condition
thank you jennings council germany's
four
okay thank you very much in that case
the committee resolves to grant
twenty slash zero two five two five
slash lbc
uh we go to our final application of the
evening this is item seven
and it's found on page 47 uh we don't
have any speakers on that so we don't
need to pause we can just jump straight
into it uh this is application
reference twenty slash zero three three
nine two slash npl
and that's darlington road ships and
it's the installation of two public
space
cctv cameras presenting officer paul
thompson
to you paul thank you chair good evening
councillors
colleagues anybody else who's still
listening um
i think you've pretty much covered it
there chair um
this is the uh this is the site here at
the north
western uh you can't see that
bear with me just a second
you can see that uh so north west and
outskirts of
shipston um
here we can see the two sites for the
cameras on
each side of darlings cook road
the ward boundary actually goes down the
middle of the road
um here we can see a photo montage of
the first camera which will go
on the leisure center is the second one
on a pole opposite the entrance to the
leisure center
and that's pretty much all there is to
say about it over to you chair the
recommendation
is to grant planning permission we have
support from the
ward member and parish council
that's wonderful thank you for that paul
okay um
we have no speakers registered do we
have any questions
for the officer from the committee
please
thank you in that i think council trump
is eager to get to the debate in fact
he's had to propose
the uh approval um do you wish to speak
on that councillor crump
just very briefly i think it makes sense
the ward members summed up
the benefits and i fully support this
and hope everybody else will agree to
accept this grant this application thank
you thank you councillor
yes it's second to all i'm sorry
outside has already beat you at this
council mill's apologies so
which has been seconded i i presume
councillor jennings doesn't want to
speak unless he wants to mute now
well i've got this 10 minute speech all
prepared but i'll
save it the next time thank you that's
much appreciated
all right um let's go to the vote on
this um it's been proposed
and seconded
that's unanimous chair
excellent thank you very much uh
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference twenty slash
zero three three nine two slash f u l
i don't think we have any urgent
business for the evening in which case
i think it totally reminds me to thank
the officers the members of the public
and indeed the members of the committee
tonight for everything you've done
and i can now close the meeting at six
minutes past eight
thank you thank you